you
hello and welcome to the programming for
a fundamental investor tutorial series
if programming or fundamental testing
sounds daunting to you don't run off
just yet everything here is going to be
starting from scratch you know including
the fundamental investing part and even
where do we get data to make our
decisions all that kind of stuff and
just as a quick note this is all for
educational use I am NOT responsible for
any financial decisions you make even if
you use this tutorial to help you make
them so a little bit of history on the
use of computers for investing you know
this is really nothing new though the
technical analysis high-frequency
trading
algo trading definitely dominates the
field when it comes to using programming
and computers to aid them and there's
really just gobs of books and other
media dedicated towards this use so I
thought would be actually kind of
interesting to make a series dedicated
towards the use of programming for
fundamental investing and fundamental
investors the purpose of the computer
here is going to be to help you in the
discovery process of the companies that
might make good fundamental investments
I also plan to cover multiple of the
specific strategies for different types
of fundamental investing so you know
what what a growth investor might want
to use a computer for versus what a
value investor might want to use
programming for etc so you like with
algo trading high-frequency trading the
computers use is mostly because humans
simply can't either do the math quick
enough or actually execute the trades
quick enough or of the combination of
those so here even though like the pace
is slower the stack of eligible
companies is still just monumental right
so what we want to do is actually use
the computers to aid us in the initial
research and digging around for
companies simply to help us locate all
of the eligible candidates because you
know even for someone trying to keep up
with let's say just the quarterly
earnings for the companies and just the
S&P 500 now this is a pretty daunting
task and that's ignoring everything else
required for a fundamental investor so
some background on me and what I do I
founded the website sent Dexcom which
performs sentiment analysis on company
speculation
for all of the news and information
online about companies I've got a
program that reads and analyzes all of
that in real time so well that's like
you know quite a bit deeper than what I
want to achieve here in this series I do
know firsthand that computers are just
plain awesome and really really useful
if you if you know how to use them and
also I think that they can be used to
enhance more forms of investing than
just technical analysis and I'm sure you
know a lot of the major firms and maybe
even smaller investors are using it but
there's just such a small amount of
information online as far as using
programming for this I thought you know
putting out a series would definitely be
something really really helpful for the
investing community and its really
technical investing seems to get like
all that attention right that sex appeal
of it or something so anyway if you have
no programming experience at all that's
fine you can still start these tutorials
completely from scratch without knowing
anything keeping up and understanding
like the programming aspect might be
difficult for you but you can just
straight-up copy everything if you are
interested in actually learning what's
happening for you know real Python is
really a pretty simple programming
language and isn't too difficult to
understand or use you should be able to
also just kind of read what you know
what I'm typing out it should just kind
of make some logical sense right anyway
but you will be using Python the reason
with Python is a good choice in my
opinion is it's not limited by large
numbers so many of the programming
languages even some of the most popular
ones today are still plagued by this max
integer value of 2.1 for 7 billion
obviously many companies have metrics
and dollar values that exceed that
number so a language that can work with
numbers greater than this is a necessity
also my channel contains tons of
programming videos as well specifically
for Python some other languages but
mostly this is all dedicated to Python
and I don't ever cover anything in my
tutorials that either I don't explain in
that tutorial at the time or that I
don't already have just a dedicated
tutorial video on it so if you're lost
confused whatever feel free to leave a
comment send me a message send me an
email
I'm here to help I love this stuff and
so I'm always real happy to talk about
it so don't be shy
lastly I was trying to figure out how I
was going to maybe organize these videos
in this series I think that the best way
to do it is just to have like one big
fundamental investing series and then
all the various types and how you might
program within it so what you can do is
you could skip you know two specifically
what you're looking for but you might be
skipping over a lot of kind of like the
baseline of the like the programming
that we're going to be using most of our
stuff is going to be either making use
of some data sets that I have
or from visiting at least within my
plans is mostly going to be from pulling
data off Yahoo so you might miss some of
the tutorial on how to do that so if
you're if you're experienced with
programming you can probably skip if
you're not then I do suggest that you
kind of go in order anyways even if
you're not too concerned about these
other techniques it still would make
sense for you to follow along so anyway
if all this sounds interesting to you
then we should definitely begin the
first thing that we're going to do is
assuming that we're first of all we are
starting from scratch so we're going to
assume that some of you guys don't
actually have Python installed if you do
have Python installed then you can just
go ahead and continue on to the next
video if you don't have Python installed
then here's how you're going to need to
install it first you're going to go to
your browser you're going to have to
visit python.org so just hop over there
once you get on site what you're going
to want to do is go to the downloads
section and what we want is actually
Python 2 7 don't download Python 3 even
if you think it's a newer version is
better no what we want is Python 2 7 so
depending on what kind of operating
system you're on you know if you're on
Linux you probably going to be pulling
out to the tarball I'm on Windows right
now so I'm gonna use the windows
installer Bravo so there's Mac OS and
all that so then you know download
whichever one you have and then just
install it at least the windows
installer is quite simple you just
literally install it and whenever that's
done you should be able to go to your
Start bar or whatever you have type in
Python and you should have both a
command line
line and something called ID le or idol
and Idol is what we're going to be using
to program it when you first pull it up
it looks like this to get to a blank
page or you know kind of like a notepad
version what you're going to want to do
is go to file new window and that will
bring up something that looks more like
this and this is what we're going to be
programming in so that's how you would
get there and obviously you can go and
save it and just as a quick note when
you do go to save it it's always going
to default as like all files all right
and so actually you're going to want to
at the end of your file name you're
going to want to end with dot py every
time you save it otherwise it's not
going to save it as a Python file just
as a quick aside that can get kind of
annoying so anyways once you've got it
installed and once you've found your way
to this empty screen you'll be ready to
continue on in the next video